في سياق اقليمي مضطرب يقدم المغرب في راي
مراقبين نموذجا سياسيا يبدو مغايرا في
ادراك طبيعه المتغيرات في مجتمعه ومحيطه
تجلى هذا في تجاوب المؤسسه الملكيه وتوصف
بالمخزن في الخطاب السياسي المغربي في
اصدار دستور جديد تجاوبا مع مطالب الاصلاح
في البلاد قبل ست سنوات واخيرا اظهر الملك
محمد السادس حسما في معالجه اسباب
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها منطقه الحسيمه منذ
اكتوبر الماضي وامر الحكومه بالتحقيق في
اسباب عدم تنفيذ المشاريع التنمويه في هذه
المنطقه تقرير محمد ابراهيم
ونعود لء قضيه الحسيمه على راس الاوامر
الملكيه في المغرب الملك محمد السادس
يتراس اجتماعا لمجلس الوزراء ويعرب عن
استيائه من عدم تنفيذ المشاريع التي
يتضمنها البرنامج التنموي في الحسيمه شمال
البلاد ويوقف اجازات وزراء ويطلب تحقيقا
في القضيه خطوه وصفت بانها موقف حاسم من
الملك في اطار الاجراءات العقابيه التي لن
تستثني احدا في قضيه تعطيل مشاريع منطقه
الريف وتحديد المسؤوليه عن التقصير ومنذ
عام 2015 اطلق المغرب اكثر من 500 مشروع
في الحسيمه عرفت باسم الحسيمه مناره
المتوسط بقيمه تعادل نحو 700 مليون دولار
الا ان المشاريع رافقتها بيروقراطيه في
بعض محطاتها وتاخر في التنفيذ بسبب سوء
اداره المشاريع من قبل بعض المسؤولين
وتشهد الحسيمه احتجاجات منذ اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي للمطالبه بتحسين اوضاع
المنطقه التي يرى سكانها انها مهمشه
واتخذت المظاهرات مع الوقت طابعا اجتماعيا
وسياسيا تدخل العاهل المغربي محمد السادس
بشكل مباشر على خط الازمه من خلال مجلس
الوزراء يراه مغاربه دليلا على جديه رسميه
في معالجه الازمه وعلى تحميل الوزراء
المسؤوليه عن انجاز المشاريع المتاخره
امام المواطنين
والملك منذ ربيع 2011 تعامل ملك المغرب مع
تطورات في بلاده في اطار برنامج اصلاح
واسع اطلقه حينها بما عرف بمبادره الملك
محمد السادس دل كما يبدو على حرص في
التعامل بمرونه مع متغيرات الواقع
الاجتماعي والسياسي في البلاد فشهد المغرب
عام 2011 اصلاحات دستوريه مهدت لانتخابات
برلمانيه ديمقراطيه عام 200
تصدرها حزب العداله والتنميه ذو المرجعيه
الاسلاميه وتبيعها انتخابات جهويه وبلديه
في عموم البلاد لم يقتصر ما يمكن تسميته
بالنموذج المغربي على التعامل مع
المتغيرات في الوضع الداخلي فقط حيث يسجل
المغرب الدور الذي قام به في تهدئه
الازمات في بعض الدول العربيه حيث رعى
اتفاق السخيرات بين الفرقاء اللبيين عام
2015 كما حرص العهد الم على فتح خطوط
تواصل مع القاره الافريقيه من خلال زيارات
متعدده في دول القاره بعدما انهى القطيعه
مع الاتحاد الافريقي وارسل عاهد المغربي
خلال زياراته تلك لبناه اسس جديده للتعاون
بين دول الجنوب بمشاريع تنمويه واقتصاديه
لم تغفل الابعاد الثقافيه والانسانيه
والاجتماعيه يعتقد مراقبون ان ملك المغرب
من خلال انتهاج الانفتاح الداخلي وتوسيع
الدور الحكومي ومنح صلاحيات واسعه
للبرلمان في اداره البلاد اعطى بلاده
خصوصيه في التعامل مع الشان الداخلي
واستطاع تخطي عقد كثيره وجنب المغرب تبعات
ازمات عصفت بكثير من دول
المنطقه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من الرباط ادريس العيساوي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومعنا هنا في الاستديو دكتور محمد
المختار الشنقيطي استاذ الاخلاق السياسيه
وتاريخ الاديان في جامعه محمد بن بن خليفه
اهلا بك دكتور وابدا مع ضيفي من الرباط
ادريس العيساوي سيد ادريس العيساوي كيف
قوبلت خطوه الملك في
المغرب هذه الخطوه وهذه المبادره في
الواقع التي تندرج في
سياق الادبيات المعروفه اليوم عن القصر
الملكي استقبلت بارتياح كبير لدى مجموعه
الراي العام الوطني وفي وخصوصا ان في هته
ايام العيد جاء بلاغ الديوان الملكي على
شكل نوع عامل يفرج الجو الذي كان محتقنا
منذ مده بخصوص هذه الازمه التي عرفتها
عرفها شمال المغرب فبالتالي كان لقي
ترحيبا من قبل السياسيين من قبل المجتمع
المدني في تقديري ا دكتور شنقيطي ما دلاله
ان يتدخل الملك بهذا الشكل وينصت للشارع
ويتدخل في الوقت المناسب بحيث يمتص كما
قال ضيفي من الرباط يمتص غضب الشارع و
يعني يقدم له ما يريده انا اعتقد ان
اي الملك المغرب الملك محمد السادس ادرك
بحكمه انه الاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه علاجها
هو مز زيد من التنميه كما ادرك من قبل ان
الاحتجاجات سياسيه علاجها هو مزيد من
الحريه كما راينا مع بدايه الربيع العربي
حينما قبل الدستور وهذا حقيقه هذا هو جوهر
علاج الازمات العربيه التي نعيشها اليوم
مزيد من الحريه الامتصاص الازمات السياسيه
مزيد من التنميه لامتصاص الازمات
الاجتماعيه والتحقيق في المقصرين يعني
بالضبط هو ما ما ما ما يترتب على ذلك من
اجراءات داخليه في المغرب سواء يتعلق
بالحكومه وغيرها يدخل ضمن هذه الرؤيه وهذا
حقيقه هو اهميه النموذج المغربي في
التعاطي مع الازمات على على عكس كثير من
الدول العربيه الاخرى للاسف التي خرجت
الامور فيها عن السيطره بسبب تاجيل
الاصلاح او الوقوف في وجه الاصلاح دلاله
هذا هو ان هنالك نموذجا يمكن ان تستفيد
منه دول عربيه كثيره وتتجنب المسار الصعب
والسبل المتعرجه ذات الثمن الفادح جدا في
في السير الى طريق الاصلاح هذا النموذج
وبذات بالنسبه للملكيات العربيه هذا نموذج
يحته حقيقه صحيح ان المغرب ليس بعد ملكيه
دستوريه بالمعنى التقليدي الموجود في
اوروبا وفي كندا مثلا لكن على الاقل وص
الى درجه ما يسمى في العلوم السياسيه مكست
ماركي يعني ملكيه مختلطه اصبح للشعب الصوت
وللبرلمان الصوت
ولحكومته الصوت والشراكه مع القصر وهذا
تطور سياسي مهم يدل على وجود النفق واضح
للتغيير ولامل للشعب بحيث انه تفادي اي
انفجارات اجتماعيه او سياسيه في المستقبل
سيد ادريس
العيساوي الملك دع الى تجنب التاسيس في
المشاريع الاجتماعيه والتنمويه وايضا دع
الى فتح تحقيق في تقصير الوزراء المعنيين
بمشاريع الحسيمه وكان سابقا ايضا في عام
2011 مع بدايه الربيع العربي كان اجرى
تعديلا دستوريا و جرت بعدها انتخابات
ديمقراطيه اوصلت حزب العداله والتنميه الى
اي حد تعامل برايك الملك المغرب
بانفتاح بحيث جنب البلاد ما حل ببلاد اخرى
لم يتعاطى حكامها بنفس
الطريقه
ا نتذكر جميعا على انه ما وقع من في اطار
احداث ما يعرف بالربيع العربي
كانت رده فعل الملك بكثير من المرونه
والذكاء السياسي انه استوعب الخطاب الذي
اتى من الشارع لم يضر يعني لم لم يجعل
ظهره امام هذه المطالب بل تعامل معها
بطريقه ايجابيه وطرح كل يعني هناك خطاب
بشهر مارس يعني 2011 وهو خطاب تاريخي كان
فاصلا في السياسات العموميه قبل من قبل
ذلك وحتى على مستوى التموقع كنظام للحكم
فكان هذا التجاوب لكن اعتقد ما وقع في
الحسيمه منذ ثمانيه اشهر اثار حفيظه الملك
لماذا لانه هناك مشروع كبير دخل فيه الملك
للتصالح ولقطع مع ما كان يعرف بماضي
الرصاص بهته بكل انحاء المغرب وخصوصا في
هته المنطقه التي لها جروح غائره في في
الذاكره الجماعيه ولكن استطاع ان يحول ذلك
الى تعامل ايجابي الى حيث انه شعبيته ضمن
هذه المنطقه وه يعني هذا الجزء من الشعب
اصبح يعني شعبيه كبيره اعتبار لانه بدا
يتعامل مع ذلك لكن هناك مشروع كبير ذ بعد
اقتصادي اجتماعي استراتيجي لانه منطقه
الحسيمه تقع في المناطق التي من المفروض
ان تكون ق قطبا اقتصاديا مهما في المستقبل
لكنها اليوم تنقصها عديد من الامور وهي
التي دفعت بالناس للخروج للشارع وهذا ما
حز في نفس الملك ان تكون هنا ان تكون هناك
مقاربه ان يكون مشروع ولا يتم تنفيذه هذا
ما دفعه بان يذهب الى حد الاعراب عن عن
غضبه وعن امتعاضه ولكن ك هناك اشاره اخرى
ان التعديلات التي تمت على مستوى مسؤولين
على مجموعه من
القطاعات الاداره الاداره العموميه عين
اشخاصا سيتكلف بهذا البحث الميداني والذي
سيحدد المسؤوليات وانا انتظر ان رد انه
عمليا ستكون الامور تذهب في في طريق تصحيح
وقع هذه المك لانه طلب فعلا ان ترفع اليه
نتيجه التحقيق وحتى قطع اجازه الوزراء في
الصيف دكتور شقيتي هذه الاجراءات كلها
التي تحاسب المسؤول عن عدم اتمامه عمله
وايضا بالسياسه الخارجيه الانفتاح على
افريقيا الوزن الاقليمي الذي يملكه المغرب
ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه المغرب الان على
صعيد العربي مثلا لنختم بهذا
السؤال المغرب يقدم نموذجين نموذج داخلي
وهو قضيه احتواء كما قلت سواء احتجاجات
اجتماعيه او احتجاجات سياسيه اعطاه صلابه
داخليه وبالتالي يمكنه ان يلعب دورا
خارجيا الانسجام طبعا الدوله المنسجمه
داخليا هي الدوله التي لديها قوه ليكون
لها تاثير خارجي وطبعا التعامل مع الازمات
الخارجيه واخرها ازمه الخليج ونحن نعرف ان
المغرب عنده مصالح ضخمه جدا ماليه وغيرها
مع الامارات ومع السعوديه ومع ذلك رفض ان
ينساق في الحصار ضد
قطارس الاصلاح هذا فدور المغرب عربيا مره
اخرى هو ان يكون نموذجا في الاصلاح
الوقائي الذي يلتقي فيه الحاكم والمحكوم
في منتصف اصلاح وقائي اختم بهذه الفكره
لان الوقت انتهى داهمنا شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور محمد المختار الشنقيطي استاذ
الاخلاق السياسيه واشكر ايضا ضيفي من
الرباط ادريس العيساوي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي